I have some disturbing stats I want to
share with you about fatherless homes
and by the way some of the stats you
know I've seen this profile say I'm
going to tell you when you read some of
these stats you're going to sit there
and say that is insane by the way these
stats are from 2021 of the impact a
father makes in a child upbringing both
a girl and a boy like I said disturbing
but you will be Shell Shocked with the
stats if you get value from the video
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel let me get right into it the US
has the highest rate of children living
in a single parent household of any
nation in the world about 80 percent of
single parent homes are led by single
mothers at a rate of 23 percent of
children living with one parent and no
other adult the United States stands
over three times the world average of
seven percent of children raised by one
parent for reference the number stands
at three percent in China four percent
in India this is not an area area we
want to be competing with other
countries by the way if there is a
statistic to not be competing again this
is one of the statistics China's at
three India is at four the world's at
seven we're at 23 in America zero
bragging rights this is the stat
everybody wants to hide and this is the
stats where the side effects of this we
ain't gonna see for two decades or three
decades or longer takes a while to see
the side effects let me continue even
for children with a father present in
the home the average school age boy only
spends about 30 minutes per week with
one-on-one conversations with his father
for comparison the same boy on average
will spend about 44 hours a week
watching television playing video games
and surfing the internet in our house
there is no video games throughout the
week it's on the weekends after you read
150 Pages throughout the week then you
have the right to play video games for
an hour or two on the weekend and that's
what you have to earn you have to move
your body you have to exercise there's
certain things you need to do to get to
that point that's our household but the
stat tells you 44 hours a week of
watching TV playing video games and
surfing the internet let me continue 90
percent
of all homeless and runaway children
63 of Team suicides 85 percent of
children and teens with behavior
disorders come from fatherless homes let
me read that statue one more time 90 of
our homeless
and runaway children 63 percent of all
teen suicide 85 percent of children and
team with behavioral disorder come from
fatherless homes that is a very very big
number next fatherlessness likewise has
a direct link to teen pregnancy and
sexual activity roughly 70 percent of
teenage pregnancies come from women
raised in a fatherless home 70 percent
of teenage pregnancies
comes from fatherless homes 70 percent
that's a big number and these same women
have significantly higher abortion rates
than women raised by both a father and a
mother on the whole
fatherless kids are 20 times more likely
to be incarcerated and 11 times more
likely to exhibit violent Behavior than
children from two-parent household 20
times more okay 20 times more if a man
and a wife raise a child they're less
likely to end up in jail but they have
the same chances as children raised by
just their father you may already be
blown away by the stats before so maybe
come back and let me read this to you
Embrace for impact if you missed it let
me read it one more time listen
just stay with me don't get distracted
stay with me listen
if a man and a wife raise a child
they're less likely to end up in jail
but they have the same chance as
children raised by just their fathers
the husband and wife raise their kid the
chance of this kid going to jail is the
same as just the father raising his kids
the problem is the single mother without
a father in the picture
that can sit there and discipline the
kids give them hope values principles
all the other stuff we play different
roles this is statistic if somebody's
watching and saying oh my God you're
discounting woman you're discounting
mothers go get upset at the stats not at
me this is stats you can't get upset at
three times three is nine that's stats
I'm giving you stats that's been given
to us by the government because they
have access to these stats this is
disturbing let me continue girls with no
fathers have lower self-esteem we can
lower crime lower mental issues help the
economy lower suicide rates and decrease
homelessness by bringing back the family
nucleus there are things that my wife
can do as a mother that I can't do
there's things she can bring that I
can't bring but there are things I can
do that she can't do so now you may say
well Pat I agree I I do agree we can
lower this we can but then how can it's
not happen and here's the other question
who's to blame
who are we playing with this now you may
be listening to this saying well it's
got to be the husband and wife's fault
it's got to be the man in the women's
fault fine how come it's not the same
ratios around the world why is U.S
fatherlessness at 23 percent
everywhere else is seven percent average
so is it really the mom and dad so how
about the mom and dad in India how about
the mom and dad in China how about the
mom and dad in Germany how about the mom
and dad in Brazil how about the mom and
dad in other places why are we at 23 how
did this happen was it like this before
is it an evolution is it mainstream
media is it Hollywood
is it the fact that parents are afraid
of parenting because everybody is so
much involved you can't do that to your
kid you can't do this to your kid you
can't discipline your kid like that
whose fault is it it's someone's fault
is it the fact that hey you know we
can't really bring Church in schools and
pray and all this other I don't know
maybe that's not something you agree
with maybe it is maybe we need those
values and principles but it's
somebody's fault in America that this is
happening this is purely a systemic
issue that we're having this cannot be
like in your whole you know no it's
really it's really the community it's
the parents it's the culture it's all
this other stuff no standards are
standards we're sitting there not
educating that's not a big deal go ahead
and do that that's not a big to go ahead
and do that it's not a big to go ahead
and do that no standards have dropped
and the numbers are shown if if we
judged a country
based on
how many kids are being raised by
fatherless homes that's producing crimes
at the levels that we're getting
sex during teenage pregnancy abortion
suicide incarceration maybe we ought to
look at this
maybe this is very important maybe our
educational system sucks
Maybe
kids spend more time around teachers
than they do around their parents maybe
who do we blame the responsibility has
to lie on the nation
maybe we're either too much involved or
we're not selling take your time to get
married take your time before you have
sex with someone take your time before
you get pregnant take your time before
you have a baby protect yourself stay
home do not just go out there and have
unprotected says maybe we're not talking
about this kind of stuff maybe we are
maybe we're not the stat says we're not
selling it in the right way and we're
paying a price for it if you're in a
community that crime is high hello
you're feeling it that's the stats
so the next time you see a father that
takes their job as a father seriously
you can actually say you know we see
somebody in military uniform
guess what you say hey thank you for
your service what do you mean hey man
stats 23 fatherlessness and you're there
with your kids thank you for your
service being a father is tough good for
you guys husband and wife trying to make
this work marriage is tough salute you
make my life better and safer by raising
good kids salute to you maybe maybe we
ought to give those Awards maybe we need
to kind of recognize father of the year
award a bigger deal man if I ran a state
or a country we would be recognizing
certain behavior and turning great
fathers and mothers into Heroes
into Heroes because God knows their job
is hard
very hard not you know making their job
harder not recognizing the guys that are
doing a good job just kind of winging it
which the way we're doing it right now
stats don't favor us we got some work to
do this is an area well I will very
comfortably say America's got a lot of
work to do we've stepped away from
values and principles and we're kind of
winging it anyways and no one Masters
parenting and none of us know if we're
going to be great parents or not for
about 40 years until our kids are 40
years old by the time you know you're a
great parent you're probably not alive
because your grandkids will validate
that you were a good parent so you're
never going to know whether you were a
grandparent or not but I made a video
from all the different things I've
learned and what I apply in my life
about parenting called how to raise
successful kids if you've never seen it
click here to watch that video shout out
to those of you guys that take your job
as a father very seriously take care
everybody bye-bye